they might look nice and sound like
sunshine but they're definitely not
waifu material in today's video we're
gonna remember the times when crazy
girls got what they deserved but before
we begin if you enjoy these kind of
videos make sure to let us know in the
comments section as well as by liking
and subscribing depending on the
feedback we might make part two or a
list for the boys
kill that sets the tone of the show arya
was a girl from the capital that offered
tatsumi a place to stay when she found
him on the streets after being come by
leone she came from a wealthy family and
had a habit of offering strays a place
to stay in her mansion while she looked
and acted like a ray of sunshine she was
a psychotic demon spawn she and her
family had an interest in luring people
from the country to their place and
torturing them to death night raid
killed her family and arya was so very
much satisfyingly murdered by tatsumi
after he witnessed the death of his two
friends at the hands of arya's family
note to self never accept an invitation
to a mansion from a nice girl that is
way way
way out of your league unless you're
good at aiming and throwing stuff at
people's faces of course but yet again
what would a plate do at gunpoint
the misfit of demon king this white hair
lady was the homeroom teacher of the
class the arnos the reincarnated demon
lord was in initially a media held zero
respect towards annos however this
changes after he proves himself to her
and the way he proves himself to her
involves a sword a spell lots of blood
and some humiliation added on top after
attacking his mother arnold shoved his
big sword in this not so poor demon's
back he cursed her to live for eternity
as a lowly hybrid like the one she
despises
justice is served
elsa bell hunter re-zero when you've got
bowel hunter in your name you know your
end won't be pretty elsa got that
nickname due to her unique way of
killing by slicing open the abdomen of
her opponent this unhinged milf appeared
way back in season 1 and stuck around
till season 2 and what a satisfying end
that was after what she did to the
likeable old man rom ye all can hold a
grudge i was livid but thanks to our
beast boy garfield tinsel this grudge
ended naruto shippuden style crushing
characters with fat boulders
flair also known as freya is the main
hero and the princess of the gioral
kingdom
on the outside flair appears to be a
kind graceful and honest woman who's
very popular due to her charms of beauty
however in reality flair is unbelievably
self-centered and incredibly sadistic
she tortured karu at every turn beat him
regularly and forced him to do tricks
like a dog in order to get the drug that
she got him addicted to however once
kearu travelled back from the future and
took countermeasures to deal with the
drug he manages to escape captivity and
subjects the busty lady to physical
torture and rape before having her
appearance modified and memories erased
now his lover and slave flair
submissively accepts having sexual
intercourse with him and afterwards
joins him as his follower and the
magician hero which if you think about
it is a far worse punishment than death
for someone who preserves themselves as
a god
now this one ladies and gentlemen is my
favorite one and i believe any akame ga
kill enjoyer also has this death as
their number one satisfying death in the
series as a former imperial guard
serious has a strong fixation on justice
it's way too annoying more annoying than
shiro emiya's fixation with his ideals
originating from her father's service in
the imperial army her opinion of justice
is blunt she believes the night raid is
evil for their actions as assassins but
believes killing in service to justice
is always right which ultimately makes
her opinion of murder similar to theirs
however evidently cereu is an annoying
b-h who has a twisted sense of right and
wrong bordering on a completely black
and white view of the world such a
mentality doomed one of my favorite
girls shirley but thanks to the
flat-chested sniper retribution was
served to this crazy lady and her
satanic dog
clementine overlord another favorite
retribution served moment of mine is the
dance of death from overlord
clementine's a rogue warrior she's
around her 20s and although her short
blonde hair and delicate features give
her a cute cat-like appearance this lady
is not right in the head her armors made
from the medals she's taken as a trophy
of the adventurous she slain clementine
is a true psychopath obsessed with
inflicting pain and murder having a
background in a strong party
clementine's extremely confident in her
abilities going so far as to declare
herself unbeatable however as the laws
of physics go when an unsophisticated
object meets an unmovable object
something's bound to break and in this
case it was clementine's bones that got
cursed by lord eins's warm hug and oh
boy it was satisfying seeing the medals
of tortured souls drop one by one before
big daddy bone finished it under the
moonlight
[Music]
school days this is a tricky one to talk
about since it's been a while that we've
watched the show and the [ __ ]
state of the school days doesn't help
now some of you might say sekai did
nothing wrong it was the fault of the
main he should have been here sadly this
is an only girl's exclusive list however
you might have his place in a boys list
if that's what you want to see now back
to this psycho girl sekai is known to be
both a cheerful mood maker and somewhat
of a loudmouth her cute appearance and
bright personality attract a lot of
secret fans and even though she's good
natured her emotions overwhelm her in
many situations like that time when she
kills makoto in a fit of rage after she
found out he'd been cheating on her
without any sort of guilt or remorse
however as the saying goes
fight crazy with crazy katsura fatally
slashes sekai across the neck to then
proceed to slice open set guy's abdomen
to check if she was indeed pregnant
apparently she wasn't with that
description there's no need to mention
that this show regardless of its
innocent name is not pleasant to watch
along with three other [ __ ] surprise
surprise his weapon turns out to be a
useless shield that he can't fight with
captain america laughs in the corner
after being bullied he gets falsely
accused of rape by a thot who was sadly
a redhead after the queen put on her
badass milf shoes she brought forth king
trash and princess to the court acting
as the judge and executioner the queen
ordered for malty to be executed by a
beheading along with her papa after an
electrifying integration ended however a
cunning yet merciful now for me stepped
in and suggested a more humiliating and
less bloody route which the queen
accepted and thus malty is officially
renamed [ __ ] in the series making it
canon
[Music]
and the healer squad hits again taming
another wild sadistic pink head dural
girl norn now also known as ellen is the
second princess of the dural kingdom and
younger sister of flair and like her
older sister ellen is a cold and
calculating after ordering everyone in
kearu's village to be executed that was
enough for kearu to regard her as a
dangerous target of revenge however like
the rest of the girls in the series the
main man managed to conquer and break
her with the help of a busty doggo flair
after being brainwashed and having her
memories wiped by kaeru ellen aka norn
is completely subservient to keru whom
she regards as her older brother and as
a wise man once said if they're not
blood related they can be dated
no chromo and our last pick is from a
murderer mystery her sin she was upset
with her childhood friend because sayeko
declined the sweets she made that could
kill her during the final killing game
rurulkar also killed her romantic
partner due to trust issues that she had
however like all thoughts her day came
and she committed suicide due to being
brainwashed proving once again the anime
god exists and that's about it for this
list hope you enjoyed the video and
we'll be looking forward to your
feedback for upcoming content so don't
forget to like and comment until next
time stay safe and stay weeb